Thanks hey guys I want to thank you all
for coming tonight and thank you so much
to square for hosting this event
my name is fen Jen and I am a software
engineer at a San Francisco startup
called Mehta markets and tonight I
wanted to talk to you guys about Druid
which is an open source distributed data
store that I work on so some of the
things we'll cover tonight I'll show a
brief demo of a product that's been
built on top of druid to motivate some
of the problems that druid has been
designed to solve I'll talk about the
history and the motivation of why we
decided to build our own data store and
then subsequently open source it and
then finally I'll talk a little bit high
level of the architecture of druid or
I'll show off some pictures with arrows
and hopefully you guys can figure out
what's going on so to really understand
what the problems that druid is meant to
solve I have a very brief demo of
actually a dashboard that's been built
on top of druid and this dashboard is
meant to showcase edits as they're
occurring on Wikipedia so hopefully
everyone here is pretty familiar with
Wikipedia there's a lot of pages about a
lot of different cool content and
basically anyone can go on and make an
edit what happens when someone makes an
edit is basically an event gets created
and this event gets sent to an IRC
channel that we then scrape and dump
into our data store so this event has a
different a couple of different
parameters it has a timestamp indicating
when the event occurs it has a set of
attributes or dimensions about the edit
for example the name of the page that's
being edited or the language of the page
or like information about who's doing
the edit like the user information
there's also metrics associated with
this event for example the number of
characters that were added or the number
of characters that were deleted so what
this dashboard is meant to showcase is
basically you can see as they're
trending across time
you can filter on different attributes
to see how those edits are changing so
for example I can filter on country
United States and I can filter on our
city city or San Francisco
San Francisco and then we can see that
Georgie ISM is getting a lot of edits
this week I have no idea what that is
and also California Culinary Academy has
been getting you know some love this
week which is kind of cool
and you can do things like you can
compare how different pages are being
edited across time you can zoom in on
different time granularities and you can
really explore your data you can drag
like this graph back and forth and
explore higher data is changing for
different granularities of time so all
the queries that you see right now are
being issued effectively live to our
data store called druid and if I drag
this graph to the current time the
ingestion should be relatively live as
well so we should if people start making
edits like right now we should actually
be able to see them in this dashboard
okay
okay so the dashboard I've just demold
is really a way to explore data Explorer
specifically time series or
transactional data in this particular
case it was data for Wikipedia I work
for a company called Metamarkets and
Metamarkets is not a it's not a social
media company we actually primarily deal
with transactional or event streams that
are specific to the ad tech space
however the problems that we mean to
solve with this dashboard and the
problems that we mean to solve with
Druid are basically three main things
one we want to solve the data
exploration problem so we want to be
able to arbitrarily slice and dice data
and drill into that data effectively
without any restrictions the second
problem that we want to solve is around
data ingestion so if some event occurs
for example of someone edits something
on Wikipedia we want to be able to
almost immediately ingest that event and
then also make that an event explorable
finally we are a software as a service
company so we are a cloud hosted
solution and its availability is very
important to us our systems need to be
constantly up and be able to withstand
all sorts of different failures that can
occur without going down and without
taking any downtime
so Merrill markets was founded late
mid-2010 ish and we kind of knew in the
early days that we wanted to build this
like dashboard that we want to be able
to deliver to our clients and have them
be able to explore data what we didn't
know was the data engine that we could
use the power dashboard so in the early
days of the company they were actually a
bunch of different solutions that we
tried one of the first things that we
tried was a relational database
management system if you're familiar
with relational databases you know their
their benefits are extremely well
documented my sequel and Postgres
they're extremely popular in all sorts
of different industries so we actually
ended up trying Postgres and the setup
that we use is pretty common in the data
warehousing space if you're not familiar
of data warehousing don't worry the
basic setup is you have like a star
schema you have your fact table in the
center you have your dimension tables on
the side you have your aggregate tables
and you have query caches to try and
prove try and improve query latency what
we found with using Postgres who is
basically queries that were cashed they
were generally pretty fast queries that
win against aggregate tables they were
fast to acceptable but the real problem
came with queries that hit the raw data
and anytime we needed to hit the base
fact table and scan the raw data those
query Leighton seas were pretty much
unacceptable to us for our dashboard
interact interactivity was very
important so we wanted users to be able
to click and get a get an interactive
experience and see their data like
updating without having to wait so what
we found with benchmarking Postgres was
basically the scan rate was about 5.5
million rows per second per core acquire
over about one week of data took about
five seconds which is like okay the main
problem is with queries that
time ranges longer than that and
especially with concurrent queries so a
page load with 20 queries over about a
week of data took an order of minutes
and that was a really uncomfortable not
very interactive experience every time
you actually use our dashboard so in
that Wikipedia dashboard you saw earlier
every time you click on something
there's somewhere between like 20 and 30
different concurrent queries that go to
our data store so we tried Postgres we
didn't really like it it didn't really
work out very well for us so we started
looking at other solutions to this
problem and the timeframe I'm kind of
talking about here is about early 2011
ish and in early 2011 ish no sequel key
value stores were extremely extremely
common and and within this space you
have data stores such as like Cassandra
you have like your HBase you have you
know all the big data clones of big data
clones BigTable clone sorry and all the
dynamo clones and you know they were
pretty hot so we said hey you know let's
give HBase a shot so because HBase is a
key value store there were certain
limitations as to how you could use it
for data exploration ok basically let's
say you had a very simple table very
simple data set here okay there's a
timestamp dimension there's a gender
dimension there's an age dimension and
there's like a revenue metric so if I
wanted to know how much money did I make
when the timestamp is equal to 1 the
value that you end up having to store in
a system like base is basically your t
is equal to 1 and then your revenue is
the sum of these 3 similarly if you
wanted to know how much money did I make
when con stamp is equal to 1 and gender
is equal to female and then the entry
you end up storing is you know the key
is time stamp one gender female the
revenue is the sort of the last two rows
there
so to be able or truly explore this data
set really without bounce you end up
generating a lot of things that you you
have to store in your no sequel store
and it's very easy to see that as your
data volume increases as your data
complexity increases the number of
entries you end up storing kind of
scales exponentially so what we found
with using HBase was queries were pretty
fast because you basically just didn't
like to look up into a map the solution
tended to be somewhat inflexible
basically if something wasn't like
precomputed if something wasn't pre
aggregated that you couldn't curry it
like if entry didn't exist in your HBase
data store you couldn't query it another
problem that we found was data was not
being continuously updated so because we
deal with like event streams and we deal
with transactional data we see events
constantly come in and when those events
came in we could not use the system like
HBase to explore them and then finally
the biggest problem of all for us was
the processing time the pre computation
time to figure out effectively every
permutation of combination of dimension
combinations that you could possibly
have your entire query set so so when
you have like many dimensions in your
data it's very easy for there to be an
exponential increase in the number of
entries you have to end up storing we
saw the problem with HBase but we didn't
give up right away what we actually
tried to do was we basically tried to
limit the the possible queries that a
user can make so you try and limit your
dimensional permutation expansion set
within academia there's this concept
called
iceberg cubing and iceberg cubing is
similar to what it sounds when you have
an iceberg you can think of the most of
the volume of the iceberg being hidden
under the
water and you have like a very small
amount that's like the tip similarly
with when dealing with pre-computation
of data what you try and do is you don't
try and pre compute out every single
possible query that the user can make
you kind of try and limit the queries
that they can make any trainer
shitkicker a set but even using this
method we didn't get the very we didn't
get very good results and what we found
was on a data set that was half a
million records the processing time with
eleven dimensions when we limited our
dimensional explosion to about five
dimensions took about 4.5 hours on a
1502 Hadoop cluster similarly when that
data set increased to 14 dimensions and
we're still limiting our query set we're
still limiting or like our dimensional
explosion our processing time took still
took about nine hours on a 25 node
Hadoop cluster so this was a huge amount
of time to be pre processing data and we
kind of realized that we were going
about this problem all wrong and like
using a key value store wasn't the
correct solution so around mid 2011 ish
we kind of looked around and other
solutions in this space to see if
anything else could solve our pain and
there was nothing really out there that
could so it wasn't really around this
time we started talking about maybe we
should build our own thing and we looked
at the lessons that we learned with
using relational databases and using no
sequel key value stores and what we
found was the problem with relational
databases was basically the scans tended
to be somewhat slow the problem that we
saw with no sequel key value stores was
the pre computation time just took too
long and we kind of decided maybe it's
not too hard to solve the problem that
we solved relational databases
so around May 2011 we started really
building out this system called druid
and druid is called druid because the
lead architect of druid played a lot of
World of Warcraft
so this is tribute this is our logo for
druid it's somewhat of a work in
progress right now so druid is a
distributed column-oriented data store
and if you're familiar at all with
distributed column-oriented data stores
they basically architectural e are all
somewhat similar and each sort of
distributed a column or two datastore
does a few things particularly well so
an example of Dremel you know it does a
Google stream oh it does ingestion of
like arbitrarily nested data fairly well
in a case of like Google's power drill
it has some really cool compression
algorithms druid is kind of designed to
add numbers really really quickly and
that's that's it's like main value add
there's a few other things that I think
it does pretty well it allows for sort
of arbitrary slicing and dicing of data
so you can filter your data really
without any bounds druid is designed to
be a production quality system so it's
designed to be highly available and it's
designed for an environment where
failures are like an everyday occurrence
as opposed to any sort of anomaly and
finally druid is this concept of real
time and you know real time is very much
a buzzword I think in in the data space
nowadays it's very much like big data or
cloud like everyone says they're real
time but it's like very unclear as to
what that term actually means for us in
the druid world we consider real time by
two facets one is really around the rate
of query return so when I asked my
datastore some question a how soon can I
get an answer back and we've kind of
designed the system such that
answer can return and somewhere between
zero to five seconds and we find that
for most of our customers that that
query latency is enough to provide them
with an interactive experience the other
facet of real time is around ingestion
latency and that is really around this
idea of some event occurs how fast can
my data store actually ingest this event
and then make it explorable typically
Druid can do this in sum or order of
about a second oftentimes it's in the
order of hundreds of milliseconds but we
find that interacting with our customers
that they have a pretty interactive
experience and they're pretty happy if
they can see some event that has
occurred in less than 10 seconds after
has occurred so how does the
architecture of Druid really allow for
these like two facets of real time I've
been explaining the architecture of
Druid in terms of a popular TV show in
the 90s called Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers and the idea behind Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers is whenever the
good guys have to fight the bad guys
they summon these giant robots called
Zords
and then these Zords come together and
they form this giant fighting robot
called a Megazord which then like beats
the bad guys and saves the day and druid
architectural II is very similar a druid
cluster is composed of many different
types of nodes and each of these nodes
are really specialized through certain
things very well and these different
node types come together and we form a
fully functional system that's designed
to deal with your data problems so
there's a couple of node types that I
want to talk about to kind of explain
how druid works
the first node type I'll talk about our
real-time notes and real-time nodes kind
of encapsulate the functionality to deal
with the ingestion and querying of data
streams
so basically real-time nodes
query data they make they make queries
available on data as soon as that data
is ingested and they do so by
effectively buffering all your data in
memory and periodically they take the
data that they've buffered and they hand
it off to some other node type to take
care of so it's this idea that real-time
nodes always deal with recently incoming
data and once that data becomes somewhat
outdated it kind of hands it off and
lets something else deal with it what
that something else is called our
historical nodes and historical nodes do
exactly how they're named they deal with
more historical data so data that real
time notes have handed off are passed
down to historical notes and historical
notes are like the main workhorses of a
druid cluster there are kind of dumb but
they do a few things very well like they
download data and then they serve
queries for that for that data so they
do like the parallel processing of
queries they do the distributed
computation of of queries and they do
like aggregates in front of real-time
and historical nodes we have
broker nodes and broker nodes are they
encapsulate the functionality of
basically knowing what data lives on
what pieces of the cluster so queries go
through broker nodes and broke her notes
kind of figured out what real-time nodes
or what historical nodes whole pieces of
data that correlate to that query and
broker nodes for that query down to the
historical nodes or to the real-time
nodes and then the real time historical
nodes do their computation in parallel
and then they return the results the
broker which does like the final level
of merging and returns results to the
caller
so broker notes encapsulate this query
scattered gather functionality and they
also they also support caching
okay so storage okay so what does the
data actually look like for druid druid
is designed to work with like
transaction streams and time series data
so all your events always have this
notion of a timestamp associated with it
and druid requires the times now with
every event in this particular example
this can be the data that we ingest for
Wikipedia which I showed in that demo at
the very beginning of this presentation
data it has a timestamp column with an
indication of when the event occurred it
has like a page those being edited it
has language the city the country of the
person doing the editing and it has
things like the number of characters
being added and the number of characters
that were there being deleted every time
someone added a page so druid stores
data as columns it is it is
fundamentally a column store and it is
the reason why like we can do aggregates
and we can do like filter so fast so
what we do when we store columns is we
take our page page column for example
and we ice it called dictionary encoding
where we convert every value that we see
in the page column to some integer
representation so for example this page
this page column has two values as
Justin Bieber has Kesha we map the first
ID Justin Bieber to zero we met Kasia
to an idea of one what we actually end
up storing to represent this column is
just a series of IDs so here we can see
that ID 0 Justin Bieber appeared in the
first three rows can appear in the next
three rows similarly with our language
column we basically map the language
English to an ID of zero and we end up
storing is just an array of zeros so
what's great about column stores is and
what's great about column stores and
dictionary encoding is that this method
lends itself very well to compression
when all you're doing is storing
the column becomes very easy to compress
there is a secondary index that we build
and this secondary index really allows
us to do very fast filters on top of
data so what we actually do is for every
single value that's within a column we
actually build a bitmap index for that
value now what do I mean by that in our
page column here we have two values we
have Justin be a real way of ketchup if
we want we want to basically store a
representation of all the rows of our
data set that only contain the value
Justin Bieber in this case Justin Bieber
appears in row zero one and two so we
can store some representation that that
indicates where this value appears so we
have basically this binary array where
one indicates the value is there and
zero indicates it doesn't
so for Kesha she appears in rows three
four and five and what we end up storing
to represent the rows that cache appears
in is this array where we only mark the
last three rows as being true if you're
familiar with like search engines at all
this method where all we're really doing
right now is building inverted indexes
so why do we do this well let's say if I
issued some query and my filter was I
only wanted to return those rows which
can turn contain Justin Bieber or Ke$ha
what we can do is we can look at the
business tax associate of Justin Bieber
which in this particular case are the
first two rows and we can look at the
bitmap this associate with Kesha which
in this case over the last two rows and
we just or these two or these two binary
arrays together and what we get is the
set of rows which contain one value or
the other so the bitmap index is the
inverted indexes are a very fast way for
us to determine for us to narrow down
our data set and only find those those
rows in our data set then
some specific criteria the other cool
thing about building bitmap indexes is
basically we all we have is binary erase
and binary raised are really easy to
compress so you compress a compression
method that we use is called concise
it's based off of the thesis work of a
PhD student in Italy and concise is
really just a more efficient
implementation of word a word aligned
hybrid which itself is really just a
variation of run length encoding so we
actually store our compressed bitmap
indexes and we never decompress for any
queries and what that lends itself to is
using a lot less memory when queries are
issued and subsequently faster scan
rates as well yeah so yes we always
dictionary code so both forms of like
encoding that I've talked about is
something we always do for so if
dictionary encoding is done really at a
column level and then the bitmap
encoding the bitmap index sees I was
talking about I really done for like
each value of the column so in terms of
availability druid is highly available
as I mentioned so druid supports
replication it supports configurable
levels of replication so if your data is
more important you replicated more and
kind of a cool thing that comes out of
replication is you lose a node it's no
big deal because your data is still
available and we use this to our
advantage in order to do software
updates where basically you can take one
note down at a time you can update it
you can bring it back up and you can do
this for every node in your cluster so
you get into this idea of being able to
do rolling update without any downtime
of data grid is designed to run on
commodity hardware
so really starting up a druid node is
just a matter of starting up a Java
process and then terminating a druid
node is just stopping a Java process so
really for about two years now we've
taken like no downtime to do any
software updates to droid yeah yeah so
we use multi-version concurrency control
actually because we deal with like event
streams a lot of our data tends to be
immutable so all data was on like a
historical note all data in a historical
cluster is immutable and if we do
updates or deletes we're basically
rebuilding blocks of data for certain
time ranges and those blocks enter the
system and obsolete like old old blocks
yeah so like oh right so the question
was around storage and what happens with
multiple versions of druid running
together our releases are designed to be
backwards compatible so it is actually a
very frequent case that will have like
multiple versions of kind of druid
floating around in a cluster and druid
needs to be able to support that and
able in order to do updates without
taking any downtime yeah okay so
right now what we're working on is
trying to release straight o6 and
getting a stable version of that out
there
the idea behind druid oh six is we're
really trying to make druid more as a
platform and we've been really working
on the extensibility of druid this idea
that anyone can build modules for druid
and basically just drop those modules
onto the druid platform and have things
just work so modules that we've seen
like contributed fairly recently are
around cardinality estimation we've seen
modules for approximate histograms and
quantiles and we also have like modules
that we built ourselves in order to do
approximate top k calculations similarly
we're looking at like we've actually
built data ingestion modules so we do
batch processing and batch data
ingestion through Hadoop and we do this
idea of like real-time processing using
storm and with druid oh six it should be
pretty easy for anyone to really build
their own module if you want to build
like priority modules that you want to
keep internal to your company and not
share with the world that's something
that's possible as well so this final
point here is druid does have this
notion of different node types and we
want to make it easier for people to
build their own I know types from
different modules that already exist out
there so if you have some problem that
we haven't seen before
hopefully it shouldn't be so hard to
build your own node type to solve that
problem so druid is right now written
entirely in Java and the modules to
extend through it are also they also
right now need to be in Java we've seen
contributions of ways of querying druid
that have been written other languages
because the query interface is really
just like an HTTP interface so people
have written like a Python library and
our our if you're familiar with like uh
statistics and then there's a little bit
of work on like a sequel adapter but
that's not like very mature yet
right so it's really our hope to turn
Dredmor into a platform and what we
actually have sort of in production
right now is we have batch ingestion
that's being done through Hadoop then it
kind of just hooks up with druid we have
streaming ingestion or streaming ETL
that's being done with storm that kind
of hooks into druid as well and then we
have these different components that
build on top of druid so we have
approximate algorithms that we've been
experimenting with this is like
approximate quantiles approximately
histograms cardinality estimates
approximate top case we have
visualization components similar to that
dashboard that you guys saw a little bit
earlier and then we also have machine
learning components and I have a
question mark on it because we only have
one machine learning component right now
we do robust pca to do trend detection
but it would be really nice if you're
going to contribute more machine
learning to druid that's that's
something i'm always really interested
in okay so in terms of the druid
community we were open sourced in
october of 2012 so almost exactly one
year ago we have a growing community
right now we have about around 30
contributors not everyone is like public
right now and they come from a variety
of different companies druid is in
production at several companies already
there's more information in our website
but it's always our hope to get more
people interested into it and more
people into production our support right
now is mainly through the community
forums and through our seas and we
really love contributions so
contributions anyway whether through
Docs or like answering questions or code
itself that that makes us super happy ok
so finally some benchmarks we've
benchmarked our real time ingestion or
real world data from anywhere between
about ten to a hundred thousand records
per second per node ingestion rates very
much vary with data complexity
but for the data sets that we've seen
from people these are some numbers in
one of our partner clusters this is
actually deployed at Netflix right now
they ingest at a rate about 150,000
events per second and that's about 7
billion events per day and that amounts
to about 500 Meg's a second or two
terabytes of data per hour yeah there's
a Netflix they have their own internal
deployment yeah I want to say 15 but I'm
not entirely sure I'm not I don't know
the exact numbers the cardinality is
like the highest cardinalities that
we've seen are typically in the order of
millions or right right typically like
druid has different column types and
float columns is actually one of them we
typically treat full columns as more of
a metric which is like something we're
gonna aggravate over versus a dimension
which may be something that we might
want to like filter over so the code is
in place and to to be able to support
like different column types but it's a
matter of like the use case of those
different column types does that make
sense
yeah yeah yes yes but there are like our
sharding scheme is we always charge
first on time and then we usually do
like secondary shards based on like the
cardinality of a dimension so if you
have an extremely high cardinality
dimension then we typically would build
like several different shards for that
dimension
yes yeah so each each like yeah so each
segment will always have a set of like
inverted indices associated with it so
it depends on this idea if you're if
you're treating the column as something
that you want to explore or treating the
column is something you want to
aggregate so sorry can you repeat the
question yes yes so you're actually
wearing every single segment but the
merge of the inverted indexes should be
something that should be very fast
because almost every segment would just
have like no information about that user
so actually I have a benchmark laid to
your question these scans be the last
time we benchmark it was about 33
million rows per second per core and
then our index compression we found that
using this concise compression method
our concise sets are about 70 percent
smaller than just using straight-up
binary arrays we can do an or operation
over about a million dimension values in
somewhere around five seconds so in your
particular use case where you're
scanning potentially several thousand
segments an or operation over several
thousand segments should complete
relatively fast okay so some takeaways
so drew it I think it's very good for
interactive fast exploration over large
amounts of data and druid is a good
choice if you want analytics and not
just like a straight-up key value store
druid is use
if you want to be able to do analytics
on your data as it's occurring in real
time
and if you want your system to be
somewhat highly available so you don't
want any downtime and druid is fairly
useful if you want to be able to have
extensibility and flexibility with your
data store some things that druid may
not be good for are if your data is so
small that it fits into my sequel then
like my sickle is pretty awesome and
there may not be a reason to use druid
they might be overkill if you're kind of
curring for individual entries or doing
lookups so if you're searching for a
single specific thing then perhaps druid
may not be like the ideal case and druid
because trade mainly deals with
append-only like event style data it's
not particularly good at doing like
updates or deletes so if you have like
all TP style transactions where you do a
lot of updates and deletes then druid
might not be the ideal solution and if
you don't really care about real-time
ingestion or you don't really care about
downtime at all
then there may potentially be other
solutions out there as well so as a
final note as I mentioned druid is open
source so if you're interested our
website is druid I oh we have a Twitter
handle as well I'm like learning a lot
about how to use Twitter so we do have a
lot of information about events that
were attending and like recent updates
and stuff on our Twitter feed you have
any questions we have our RC channel
some of us basically just camp out there
and just answer questions that the
community has okay well thank you all
for listening and I'd be happy to take
some questions if anyone has any yes
yes so I actually I'm sorry so the
question was around the durability of
real-time ingestion and specifically how
durable is the real-time storage nodes
that we use right so their ability with
real-time ingestion is done partially by
the nodes themselves and partially by a
message bus that we use to do like
real-time ingestion and for us the
message for us that we use is Apache
Kafka so the idea behind Apache Kafka is
it actually acts like a buffer for
incoming events and within this buffer
you can have multiple nodes like read
from the same buffer so if you have like
two real-time notes reading from the
same buffer reading the same set of
events then you get replication of
events across two nodes what Apache
Kafka also allows you to do is allows
you to reread events from some offset
for so for example if your node goes
down and it comes back like a few
minutes later then you can basically
check like the last offset that it
committed and then reread events from
that offset the the Drude notes
themselves also handle they also have
features that are built-in to do like
higher availability but like we could
perhaps talk offline about like the
architecture there because it's a little
bit more complicated oh cool any other
questions yes yes
so the number one reason so the question
was there's no downtime for software
upgrades but what other reasons do we
have for downtime the number one reason
that we've experienced downtime is
because we run on AWS and if AWS has an
outage then we will be affected we've
been working on a feature such that we
can replicate data across multiple data
centers
so we're thinking of basically having
some of our data in AWS and then some of
our data in like our own data center and
the idea is that if AWS goes down or if
our own data center goes down it doesn't
impact this yeah so druid is designed to
have no single point of failure but if
like half our cluster gets wiped out but
by nativist outage then that that
becomes a problem for us yes yeah so it
so the question was around how Trude
caches queries and druid actually caches
queries based on the fundamental like
unit of storage that and understand
which are called segments so it always
caches queries on a per segment level so
it's not a query cache it's it's a cache
for like the data pieces are accessed as
part of a query sorry I think there's
another question yes right so I'm not an
expert on some Ingeborg I only know it
at a very high level and and I think
there's probably people that are better
suited to enter this question than I am
and unfortunately not here right now
my understanding of something but it's
more like data flow control for storm
and whereas for druid it's more as like
an end a persistent storage
or processing that's done in storm so
how will you storm is we use storm to do
things like lookups and we do use it for
doing things like joins and when those
operations are complete that data then
gets fed into druid and then jus just
access the store for that data so druid
right now it has a real-time ingestion
component but all data that's ingested
by druid all has to be denormalized so
like do it has no support for drawings
so we require like something like storm
to do that so I can see a a solution to
be for like real-time ingestion to be
like summing BER plus storm plus druid
something like that cool oh one more
question
right so the question was around
synchronization of of the nodes that
store data we use do keeper to do sort
of like all intra cluster communication
and I didn't show it in the diagram but
there's basically another node type it's
called the coordination coordinator node
or a master node and that node is really
responsible for telling like historical
nodes what data to load and what data to
drop because the data that we deal with
at least on the historical cluster are
always like immutable then we get around
like problems like rican Sisseton see
because we're always dealing with
immutable data so the idea is like
there's an explicit piece that does like
coordination and there's an explicit
piece that does things like replication
and distribution of data and then the
other pieces that that are are they're
like the historical nodes are mainly
responsible for dealing with just
queries and aggregates for those queries
does that make sense okay cool cool
thanks guys